And they will not just fight over it,
they will fight to the death
over this mountain of gold.
He says, yet the fighting will be so
fierce and violent that out of every 100
99 will be killed
trying to
take or possess
or retrieve a portion of this gold.
Now,
[Arabic recitation]
there's a couple of things here that I
want to mention. This narration
has
it has a point to it, an overarching
theme,
and then it has an actual story or an
actual event. What is the finite event?
The finite event
is that the Euphrates River.
Are we familiar with the Euphrates
River?
It is it flows and it flows between Iraq
and Persia. It's kind of
almost that it separates what is
known as the Arab world and the Persian
world.
And it was actually always known as a
dividing line between those two main
cultures. The Euphrates River,
it is such a grand and pure and
beneficial river that it is one of the
four rivers of paradise.
The Nile River is the second.
And then the other two are proprietary
to paradise.
But the Euphrates River, Al-Furat,
this river
one day,
very soon,
it will
uncover a mountain of gold.
In another wording,
"Kanz min dhahab."
A treasure of gold.
When people see it,
they're going to start fighting over it.
But, as we said, this narration here has
an actual event that takes place, but it
has an overarching theme. He tells us
that when people start to fight,
the fighting will be so fierce, so
vicious, so violent
that out of every 100 participants, 99
will be killed.
They will lose their lives
to try to pocket a little bit of this
golden treasure.
Now,
here we have an overarching theme.
That's the event, but the overarching
theme is why is the prophet telling us
this? Why? Why Why do we need to know
this? As a matter of fact,
this would not happen and has not
happened yet.
So, the question is, why did the
companions,
out of all the things that were going to
happen in the future, why did the
prophet
choose this thing to point out that was
going to happen? What is the lesson to
be derived from this event?
There is a general lesson to be derived.
The lesson is is that
this narration captures
the mentality,
the psychology,
and the social structure
of humanity
during those end days.
Imagine with me
if during the time of the Jahiliyyah
Arabs,
the Jahiliyyah Arabs before Islam,
those men that we read about
that
would only die for things honor
and valor and vengeance and took pride
in authenticity
and bravery and family.
Don't we have that the Jahiliyyah Arabs
used to pride themselves on giving to
the poor?
Used to pride themselves on keeping ties
with their kin and kith, right? And kin
and kith. Did they not
take pride in being
truthful? In not being vulgar?
In all of the poetry of the Arabs, you
are hard-pressed to find any true
vulgarity,
right? To the point that the entire
Arabic language has shaped the mind
of its speaker to not be able to even
express true vulgarity in its most
offensive of senses unless they
go out of their way to do that.
The the language itself doesn't lend
itself well to vulgarity.
And so, the thing is is that
in that culture in that time, let's say
the Euphrates River uncovered that same
mountain of gold, those kinds of people,
would we find out of 99 out of 100
people, 99 would die trying to take some
of that gold?
Do you think that would happen?
A people that refuse to tell a single
lie, even if it was against their
own interest, even if it was against
their own religion.
A people
that
would say a line of poetry
and then if they were held to it would
die
defending that line of poetry just so
that they don't go down in history as
being someone who
didn't fulfill what they said.
Right?
Would they fight in that way? Number
one, no they would not.
They were above that. Those Jahiliyyah
at that time, they were above that kind
of fighting over things gold and
silver. Yes, that happens. It's not like
greed didn't exist, but it had a very
different form and it was not as vulgar
as it is today. The second thing is out
of every 100,
99 are dying. Why are there not groups?
Where are the families?
Where are the tribes? You would expect
that out of every 100 tribes, 99 would
be decimated. That's not what he said.
He said out of every 100, 99 would lose
their life.
Why? Because
this will happen during a time when the
family structure has been broken down so
thoroughly
that it is every man for himself and
money and riches are their god that they
worship.
Because a man will only die for what he
worships or what he values above all
else.
We are creatures of odds.
let's say you and I wanted to
cross the street.
So the light changes, we cross the
street.
Right?
When we cross the street,
are we not playing a game of odds?
Is it not possible that there's a maniac
that's parked right there in front of
the light and is waiting for me to cross
in front of him before he runs over me?
Is it not possible that someone doesn't
see the light?
I'm stepping out into a path of giant
one and two ton machines flying at 40
and 50 and 60 miles an hour barreling
down the road, but I still step into
that danger based on what? Based on
probability,
not possibility.
Is it possible
that there's a maniac behind the wheel
of this car and when he tells me go,
I still believe him and cross in front
of him, even though I don't know this
man from Adam? Why?
Because probably he's not a psycho.
Probably he's not off his meds. Probably
I will survive this. When I go to the
pharmacist
and when I go to the doctor and I get a
prescription,
is it not possible that the doctor is
mistaken?
Is it not possible that he's fighting
with his wife and he confused me with
another patient and gave me a
prescription that will kill me instead
of a prescription that will will heal
me? Is that not possible?
Yes, but is it probable? No, it's not
probable. And then when I take that
prescription to the pharmacist, is it
not possible that the pharmacist is busy
on his phone and he reaches for the
wrong medication and gives me poison
instead of medicine. Is it not possible?
It's possible. But but is it probable?
No, it's not probable. We go on
probabilities. So, here's my question.
The probability
of 99 to 100.
Who would take those odds?
Tell me, how cheap and worthless does
your life have to be for you to agree to
the odds of 99 to 1?
Say, "Hey, you want to play this game?
99 to 1.
99% chance you'll die
a horrible death, but there's a 1%
chance that you might be a rich man. You
want to play?"
"Yes, I'll risk everything right now."
For those odds.
You will only do something that if
you positively worship money. That is
the only kind of person that will do
that.
Who would agree to those odds? That's
what we call insanity.
And so, the prophet Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam, he tells us here that
at the end of time, just before the
hour, the Euphrates will uncover a
mountain of gold. Out of every 100
combatants, 99 will lose their lives in
pursuit of that gold. Each of them
thinking that he will be the one to take
it.
That's what he said.
The prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam
said,
Each one of them looks at those odds of
99 to 1 and still proceeds to enter into
that competition. Why? Because each of
them is convinced that he will be the
one
percent and not be the 99%.
What do we call this in modern culture?
Huh? No. We have a word for it today.
Not even gambling.
That
Not even gamblers, not even addicted
gamblers
would take those odds.
Irrational? Mhm, it's irrational, but
that's not the the word for it. It's a
It's a pop
pop culture word.
Main character syndrome. Very good. What
is main character syndrome?
I am the Disney prince.
Right? I'm Aladdin.
I'm not Jafar. I'm Aladdin.
I am the main character. I'm the hero of
the story. You see all this? See all
these people?
They're all only here to facilitate my
existence.
All these people, they're just here to
facilitate my journey and my ascension
to greatness.
I'm the one that the stars aligned for,
as they say.
Right?
Have you
Who Now they they we have in our modern
culture
you're a king, you're a queen. Don't be
a worker, be a boss. Show up. Be a
Be an entrepreneur. Be famous.
What's wrong with being a worker? What
is wrong with that? What is wrong with
being a follower?
What is wrong
with just being a regular person? what
happened to that?
No.
If you want to be a regular person,
you have no ambition.
Because ambition and greed now are
synonymous.
Right? And Machiavellian
and outgoing are now synonymous.
This is because our people, our time,
society, and humanity have largely
become godless and debased.
And they debase themselves constantly
for the smallest and slightest of
gratification.
Right? And so that's why a mountain of
gold will work on them.
It would not have worked on other major
societies.
What about if those 100 people all said,
"Guys, we're all killing each other. 99
to 100, 99 to one are the odds. How
about
we just split it into 100 portions, and
each of us take one portion. We all
live."
Why wouldn't they do that? That's what
humans do, you know.
Why wouldn't they do that?
Greed,
arrogance,
self-centeredness,
hubris,
delusion.
That's why.
And so
this is a snapshot
of what the world will be like
specifically in that region
just before the emergence of a Dajjal.
And so when we read narrations about a
Dajjal will emerge,
and most people will fall to his fitna,
why is that? Because this is the kind of
people there are at that time.
This is the caliber of people.
People are willing to die
[Arabic recitation]
subway to pick up their phone
cuz that's worth your life.
But if you defile their mother or defile
their daughter or their sister,
you know, she's free. She could do what
she wants, you know, she
That's her choice. You understand?
That's the kind of
environment that we're in.
A person who has things that they stand
for,
right? They are considered to be
delusional
simpletons.
If a person says,
"I
choose
to go hungry than to extend my hand and
beg from someone," they will call that
arrogance. That's not arrogance.
That is exactly what makes a man.
That is the epitome of true strength of
character. Because a person because a
man who has a price is no man at all.
Right?
Those values are going to become almost
extinct. Almost.
Almost extinct.
And this caliber of person will be the
ones that will inherit the earth at that
time.
Right? That will take over the earth at
that time.
As the prophet describes, sallallahu
alayhi wasallam.
But there's one more thing to say and
we'll end with this.
The Euphrates river, does it run between
Muslim or non-Muslim countries?
So if that's the state of the Muslimin,
what is going on with the rest of the
world
during those days?
This is why this narration
was so relevant for the prophet
Sallallahu alaihi wasallam to
[Arabic recitation]
30 minutes away. Ramadan, you were here
for Fajr every single day.
[Arabic recitation]
And what once a week?
Once a week?
Friday.
You think so?
I don't think so.
You don't think so? I don't know.
Okay, so what do you do?
You know what I want?
God bless you.
You remember?
God bless you. You remember?
You remember how you did it?
You remember that? I remember that.
You remember that?
I remember that.
You remember?
I remember.
You remember that?
[Arabic recitation]
would doubt him in the morning.
That's all I know.
Even by the
they won't be here.
In sha Allah.
Yeah. Yeah. In sha Allah.
And so maybe I'll see you on Friday or
over the weekend.
In sha Allah. I'm looking at
[Silence]
No. Every day in the morning and in the
evening to go through the history of the
mosque.
That would be super nice.
And and and I mean you could literally
just choose any day that you
I'd love to have you.
I'd love to have
Okay.
Hey, do you know what's good though
about that one?
I mean it's not love.
Yeah, but I'm going to go
So love is not supposed to
Whatever it was
It's very small.
I got 20 bucks.
So then I have to pay you.
[Arabic recitation]